Новини дня «heute» з Барбарою Гальвеґ.
Добрий вечір і ласкаво просимо,
радіємо нашим глядачам,
зокрема Норберт Леман, який
згодом розповість новини спорту.
Тож ми маємо для вас такі теми:
«Ви можете покластися на Німеччину!» -
заявив президент Німеччини Штайнмаєр
під час свого візиту до України
і запевнив народ у подальшій солідарності.
Компроміс на горизонті:
у суперечці щодо входженнякитайської державної
судноплавної компанії «Cosco»
в порт Гамбурга замерехтіла угода.
Новий прем'єр-міністр Великої Британії вступив на посаду
Ріші Сунак хоче об'єднати глибоко розділену країну
і виправити помилки своєї попередниці.
У квітні українська влада все ж відмовила
німецькому президенту у візиті,
тоді вона була не надто прихильно налаштована
до Німеччини та її колишнього міністра закордонних справ.
Штайнмаєр відповідальний
за політику ФРН щодо Росії,
та після російського нападу він публічно визнав свої помилки.
Сьогодні політичного діяча вітали в Україні.
Тож він відчув війну і на собі.
Репортаж Лени Зюндербрух.
Триває дев'ятий місяць з початку російської агресії,
але це перший візит президента Штайнмаєра за весь час.
Це знак солідарності
у фазі підлих російських авіаударів у всій країні,
заявив він сьогодні вранці в Києві.
Моє послання до українців таке:
Ми не тільки на вашому боці.
Але ми й надалі підтримуватимемо Україну:
економічно, політично, а також у військовому плані.
У невеликому містечку Корюківка
на півночі країни
відбувається виняткова демонстрація того,
що означає війна для його мешканців:
повітряна тривога змушує
федерального президента перенести свої зустрічі
з мешканцями до бомбосховища.
Корюківка - це:
Місце, де громадяни
проявили неабияку мужність, ставши з голими руками
проти танків
і фактично змусивши їх зупинитися.
Розмови з жителями, подібні до цієї на хлібозаводі,
відбуваються в Україні сьогодні лише з третьої спроби.
Штайнмаєр дійсно хотів відвідати країну в середині квітня.
Але буквальноперед від'їздом він отримав відмовуз Києва.
У Берліні це було розцінено
як дипломатична і політична образа.
Україна критикує Штайнмаєра за його проросійську політику
на посаді міністра закордонних справ та підтримку
суперечливого газопроводу «Північний потік-2».
Минулого тижня друга спроба
була відкладена з міркувань безпеки.
Тепер Штайнмаєр демонструє під час туру Києвом
з мером Кличком,
що Україна може покладатися на Німеччину.
Це також має з'ясуватисяпід час розмови
з президентом Зеленським.
Запитаємо у Дари Гасанзаде в Києві,
як оцінюють цей візит Штайнмаєра?
Чи вдалося врегулювати суперечності?
Я б сказав, що так.
Хочу також підкреслити,
що більшість спірних питань
були вирішені ще до візиту.
Особливо багато проблем було через постачання зброї.
Україна бажала більше, швидше та важче озброєння.
Адже країна була беззахисною,
коли жителів бомбили з повітря,
а потім прийшли постачання з Німеччини.
Тож спалахнула надія
від обіцяної допомоги на відбудову.
Це промінь надії для багатьох українців.
Чи наголошував президент
на інших спеціальних проєктах?
Так, обидва президенти домовилися про патронаж над містами.
Це має символічний характер,
але глави держав хочуть розвивати
побратимство міст і далі.
Про це говорили і в минулому,
що велика сила Європи полягає в тому,
що люди збираються разом, пізнають одне одного,
разом будують мирне майбутнє.
Дякую за репортаж з Києва, Даро Гасанзаде.
Російські напади на Україну
вже завдали збитків
на сотні мільярдів доларів.
Хоча закінчення війни ще не видно,
союзникина міжнародній конференції в Берліні
дали добро на відбудову країни.
Своєрідний план Маршалла,створений за зразком
американської допомоги Європі після Другої світової війни.
Репортаж Патриції Відемаєр.
Україна буде отримувати підтримку, скільки це буде необхідно,
про відбудову подбають,
і водночас країна модернізуватиметься,
так звучить одне з послань канцлера.
Йдеться про план Маршалла для України -
завдання на покоління
англійською мовою для всіх міжнародних гостей.
Йдеться про інвестиції в Україну,
яка в майбутньому постачатиме «зелену» енергію до ЄС,
стане експортером якісної продукції, цифровим центром сили,
членом ЄС з європейським правом.
Чудові перспективи, але на місцях, в Україні,
люди вже потребують фінансової допомоги,
38 млрд тільки на наступний рік,на відновлення
життєво важливої інфраструктури, на поточні витрати.
Скільки коштуватиме вся реконструкція - невідомо,
ЄС передбачає 350 млрд, Україна - 750.
Кожне євро, кожен долар, кожен фунт, кожна єна -
це інвестиція в Україну, а також інвестиція
в демократичні цінності в усьому світі.
Якщо ви інвестуєте в свою країну, ви інвестуєте в ЄС,
наголосив український президент у відеозверненні.
Україна відстоює європейську безпеку,
а не лише безпеку наших сусідів,
і з нашою допомогою ЄС
також може замінити російські енергоносії.
Окрім фінансової допомоги,
йшлося про подальшу військову допомогу,
український прем'єр-міністр подякував за постачання зброї.
Позитивні новини надходять з газового ринку,
оптова ціна на газ в Європі суттєво знизилася.
Однак до споживачів
це дійде лише із запізненням,
повідомляє міністр економіки Габек.
Він провів консультації
із європейськими колегами в Люксембурзі,
на них ішлося про спільну закупівлю газу
та дуже дискусійну тему обмеження максимальної ціни на газ.
Детальніше про це - Ульф Реллер.
Станом на восьму годину ранку
з міністром економіки Німеччини Габеком все гаразд.
Міністри ЄС продовжують шукати шляхи
вирішення енергетичної кризи,
але той факт, що вони шукають разом,
вже має ефект для Габека.
Сама перспектива, оголошення про те,
що ми збираємося це зробити, призвела, зокрема, до того,
що ціни знизилися.
Послання міністрів енергетики полягає в тому,
щоб робити щось разом,
особливо купувати частину газу, який нам потрібен, разом як ЄС.
Політики хочуть тиснути на ціни ринковою силою Європи.
Якщо ми об'єднаємо наші європейські потужності
для заповнення сховищ у наступному році,
ми зміцнимо безпеку постачань і знизимо ціни.
Динаміка вартості газу за останні роки свідчить про проблему:
на початку 2021 року середня ціна 1МВт/год
становила лише 20 євро.
Згодом, у серпні цього року,
після припинення газопостачання Росією,
ціна зросла до 342 євро
і зараз впала до менш як 100 євро.
Федеральний уряд, як і раніше, відкидає обмеження ціни на газ,
тобто встановлення максимальної ціни, але допускає винятки.
Коли ринки зростають, коли відбувається зовнішній шок
і ринки відкриті для спекуляцій,
саме це час для втручань.
ЄС повільно рухається до спільної енергетичної політики,
вкрай необхідної.
Адже ціна на газ залишається спільною проблемою.
Чи слід дозволити китайській державній компанії
придбати частку в терміналі порту Гамбурга?
Уряд Німеччини сперечається
про це вже кілька тижнів поспіль.
Канцлер виступає за, шість міністерств поки що проти.
Критики побоюються, що Китай отримає вплив
на критично важливу інфраструктуру в Німеччині.
Китай вже володіє акціями
різних європейських портових компаній,
зокрема Антверпена і Роттердама,
великих конкурентів Гамбурга.
Більше завантаження потужностей та контейнерів,
більший товарообіг -
ось на що сподівається гамбурзький порт.
Нині з'явилися ознаки компромісу,
вважає Ральф Ціммерман фон Зіфарт.
«Toller Ort» - найменший
з чотирьох контейнерних терміналів Гамбурга.
Порт розташований в центрі «ганзейського» міста,
і очікувана участь китайської
судноплавної компанії «Cosco»
в компанії-операторі, підкреслюють прихильники,
не передбачаєпродажу землі або інфраструктури.
Гамбурзький порт має докласти значних зусиль,
щоб зберегти або підвищити свою конкурентоспроможність.
Якщо ми втратимо цю угоду з Cosco
і компанія перевезе вантажі деінде,
у порт Зебрюгге чи інші західні порти,
то це буде ще одним важким ударом для Гамбурга.
Гамбург довго чекав на таке іноземне втручання,
тож момент, у який треба ухвалити складне рішення,
здається особливо невдалим для німецьких воріт у світ.
І все ж це не вияв наївності.
Ми споглядаємо на світ, ми - також його частина.
І нам відомо про становище в Китаї.
Ми усе чудово усвідомлюємо.
Ми також поважаємо занепокоєння
уряду Німеччини.
Навіть компромісне рішення
про менш ніж чверть того,
задля чого сьогодні шукають
консенсус у Берліні,
декого у «світлофорній»
коаліції не влаштовує.
Це складне питання,
і як я часто кажу,
у природі немає такого
поняття, як «трохи вагітна».
Ви або ведете бізнес
з китайцями, або ні.
І ми наполегливо радимо цього не робити.
Якщо навіть до завтрашнього засідання
Кабінету міністрів у Берліні
вдасться досягти компромісу,
питання фундаментальності
таких стратегічних інвестицій
все ще видається
далеким від вирішення.
Перша урядова заява
нової голови уряду Італії
Джорджі Мелоні: в ній лідерка
ультраправої партії«Брати Італії»
гарантує дотримання чинних законів ЄС.
Однак вона висловлюватиме пропозиції
щодо покращення та
відстоюватиме інтереси Італії,
зазначила 45-річна посадовиця.
Мелоні прагне запобігти потраплянню
мігрантів до Італії морським шляхом.
За її словами, слід перевіряти, чи
мають люди в країнах
Північної Африки право
на політичний захист.
Було допущено чимало помилок,
та він хоче їх виправити.
Про це сьогодні заявив Ріші Сунак,
новоспечений прем'єр-міністр
Великої Британії.
Король Чарльз офіційно надав Сунаку
дозвіл на формування уряду.
Перед урядом постали
серйозні виклики.
Іна Балтес - наживо з Лондона.
Будинок №10 на Даунінг-стріт
тепер належить йому,
Ріші Сунак - вже третій
прем'єр-міністр
та мешканець цього дому за два місяці.
Попереду у нього, мабуть,
найважча робота в Британії.
Були допущені помилки,
і я був призначений
лідером своєї партії та
прем'єр-міністром, аби їх виправити.
Часу обмаль: обраний лише вчора,
сьогодні вранці він мчить містом
до короля Чарльза.
Тепер 42-річному Сунаку
доведеться заспокоювати
країну, партію і передусім - біржі.
Основою мого порядку денного
стане економічна стабільність
та довіра.
Це означає, що попереду
непрості рішення.
Конкретних планів сьогодні немає,
але очікується режим
максимальної економії.
Сунак також може скоротити
медичні та соціальні виплати.
Це дуже боляче вдарить по населенню,
у нас вже зараз різко
зростають витрати
і падає рівень життя.
Це рекордне погіршення
за останні десятиліття.
Ліз Трасс звільняється, а разом
з нею йдуть і деякі міністри.
Новий склад уряду вже формується.
Ріші Сунаку не варто гаяти час.
Держава витрачає близько
660 млн євро на рік
на фонди партій,
аби вони могли виконувати
свою освітню функцію:
у SPD це Фонд Фрідріха Еберта,
у CDU - Фонд Конрада Аденауера.
Ще один мають CSU, FDP, партія
Зелених та Лівих.
AfD хоче, щоб її фонд також
отримав фінансування,
і подала позов, який сьогодні
розглядатиме Конституційний суд.
Детальніше розповість Сара Такке.
Судді другого скликання
зібралися тут сьогодні,
щоб розглянути фундаментальне
питання про те,
чи має держава фінансувати
політичну освіту для правих сил.
Тому що пов'язаний з AfD
фонд Дезідеріуса Еразма
хоче отримати ті ж самі дотації, що
отримують фонди інших партій.
Ми єдиний фонд, який позиціює
себе консервативним,
і на цьому тлі
вся течія в країні маргіналізується.
Фонд імені Дезідеріуса Еразма
під керівництвом Еріки Штайнбах
може розраховувати на майже
70 млн євро з податкових коштів.
Фонд хоче використати ці мільйони
на фінансування заходів,
як цей, що відбувся в листопаді
2021 року в замку на Рейні,
де розглядалася економічна політика.
Фонд хоче використати отримані кошти
на організацію ще більш
масштабних семінарів та конференцій,
закупівлю навчальних матеріалів,
а також на фінансування дослідницьких
проєктів та стипендій.
Представники Бундестагу хочуть
абияк перешкодити подібному
фінансуванню правих радикалів.
Ми стверджуємо, що не можна витрачати
гроші платників податків на
ультраправий науковий центр, кубло
кадрів, тобто фонд Дезідеріуса Еразма.
Рішення буде ухвалено вже наступного року.
І це, напевно, буде новаторство,
адже зрозуміло,
до рівних речей треба ставитися однаково,
як це гарантує Конституція.
Очевидно й, що за AfD стежить
управління з захисту Конституції
і щоблизькі йому нові праві стратеги
та ідеологи працюють у фонді.
Тому рекомендація з Карлсруе
полягає ﻿в тому, що варто закріпити в законі
таке положення: фінансуванню
підлягають лише фонди,
які базуються на засадах Конституції.
У будь-якому разі це важливе рішення
щодо фінансування політичних фондів.
Як би ви назвали те, що вважаєте
когось дійсно класним
і хочете познайомитися ближче?
«Smash», - скаже молодь.
Сотні тисяч учасників
обрали «smash» молодіжним словом року.
До речі, його також використовують
як дієслово «smashen»,
у значенні «починати щось з кимось».
Adidas припиняє співпрацю
із відомим американським
репером Каньє Вестом
через його антисемітські висловлювання.
Компанія-виробник спортивних
товарів заявила,
що не допускає антисемітизму чи
інших проявів мови ворожнечі.
Каньє Вест успішно
займається дизайном
одягу та взуття з 2015 року
у співпраці з Adidas.
Наразі спільна модна лінійка
буде ліквідована,
а платежі припинені.
Роками Вест неодноразово
викликав обурення.
Про футбол розповість Норберт,
сьогодні емоційний вечір
Ліги чемпіонів, чи не так?
«Боруссія Дортмунд» могла спокійно
вийти до 1/8 фіналу з перемогою.
Але, по-перше, це проти «МанСіті», а
по-друге, проти колишнього
гравця команди -
нападника Ерлінга Голанда.
Але у Дортмунда теж є відповідь:
найкращий нападник Джуд Беллінгхем.
Він забивав у кожній грі збірної.
19-річний англійський футболіст,
що нещодавно знову засвітився
у складі «Боруссії» в Бундеслізі,
справляє враження в Манчестері.
Досить чудове.
Ми знаємо його якості.
Але ми намагаємося грати свою гру
та перемагати.
Так само, як ми зробили в першому
матчі з затяжним ударом
Ерлінга Голанда перед
самою кінцівкою.
Очікується, що ексгравця
шанобливо зустрінуть
на колишньому рідному стадіоні.
Звичайно, це буде викликом,
у нього чимало здібностей.
Але я вірю в хлопців переді мною.
І я, безумовно, з нетерпінням
чекаю на гру.
Перемога необхідна Дортмунду для
того, щоб забезпечити собі вихід
до наступного туру, а Манчестеру для
перемоги в групі потрібен один бал.
І команда Лейпцига зустрічається
сьогодні ввечері з також
відомим клубом «Реал Мадрид».
У першому турі вони зазнали поразки
від чинних чемпіонів
з рахунком 2:0, але
в останніх семи матчах
не програли жодної гри.
Без великої трійки, Бензема,
Модріч та Вальверде,
зірковий склад королівського клубу
не втрачає яскравості.
Це відомо і тренеру
Лейпцига Марко Роузу.
«Реал Мадрид» -
чинний переможець Ліги чемпіонів,
там грає й найкращий голкіпер світу,
тож у них надійний захист на воротах.
Але, я думаю, у нас хороша футбольна команда.
До ФК «Лейпциг» повертається
нападник Тімо Вернер.
Його команді необхідно перемагати,
щоб вийти в плей-офф.
Натомість «Реал» вже кваліфікувався
до 1/8 фіналу.
Мета - посісти перше місце в групі.
Ми можемо це зробити.
Це те, до чого ми прагнемо.
Очевидний виклик
від чинних чемпіонів.
«Реал», до речі, не зазнав поразок
у 16 матчах чемпіонату.
А найяскравіші моменти всіх
матчів вищої ліги
ви зможете побачити завтра ввечері.
Рідкісне явище можна було
спостерігати сьогодні в небі,
принаймні там, де дозволяли хмари.
Часткове сонячне затемнення.
Як і тут, у Рудних горах,
у багатьох місцях зібралися
охочі з телескопами та
спеціальними окулярами,
щоб поспостерігати за рухом
Місяця попереду Сонця.
Своєї кульмінації явище досягло
невдовзі після полудня.
Примхливий жовтень:
найближчими днями потеплішає,
про це за мить
у прогнозі погоди від Оздена Терлі.
Анна Ґеллінек чекає на вас в
ефірі heute journal о 21:45.
Бажаю гарного вечора
та всього найкращого!
До зустрічі завтра.
Доброго вечора і ласкаво просимо
до прогнозу погоди.
З потеплінням клімату
останній день літа
відходить все далі і далі.
Літній день визначається
щонайменше позначкою 25°C,
і цього тижня цей показник
було досягнуто кілька разів.
Це відбувається через спеку
що накопичилася на півдні Європи.
Вона підхоплюється
масштабним антициклоном в Атлантиці та прямує
Іспанією та Францією в Німеччину.
Можливо, ви чули про це ще влітку.
Така синоптична ситуація повторюється
нині і на південному заході.
Вночі очікується дощ.
Він рухається на північний схід.
На сході буде сухо,
з температурою 13°C
і 4°C на Північнонімецькій низовині.
Завтра вранці можливі дощі,
особливо на півдні,
на півночі сухо,
з сонячними проясненнями.
А вдень скрізь буде сухо,
на півдні також вийде сонце.
Температура повітря досягатиме 23°C
на південному заході Німеччини
і 14°C на південному сході.
Найближчими днями буде ще тепліше.
У четвер - до 24°C, у п'ятницю - до 26°C.
На цьому все, гарного вечора!